in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week with me in the studio
is dr. J hat zettler founder and medical
director of the Hosen part clinic in
darmstadt welcome to the shoulder
because I fly look we just saw some of
the latest trends in cosmetic surgery so
so what's on highest demand in your
clinic well there's multiple things
which are higher demand their patients
with the need for bodywork like
liposuction on getting a new waistline
and other patients are focusing on the
face so it's a clear distinct separation
of groups which then after a little
while will cross over and get a change
over the last year's or tremendously yes
since the the public awareness and and
the media are focusing more the the kind
of important sea of aesthetic appearance
there's a different understanding and
and as methods have developed over time
things have been more predictable and
more safe and we have learned a lot so
if you would take a look at my face you
would see there are some wrinkles I
don't mean I'm not really proud of year
or my forehead and so on so there are
different things you could do to me one
is Botox and one is hyaluronic acid for
example so so what's the difference
between the two procedures well number
one I think you're very attractive so
there's not really something predominant
I would think to do but if you ask me
now about botulinum toxin and Phyllis
there's a distinct separation again boat
alarm toxin you will do in the upper
forehead and the upper third of the face
and it fillers are more placed in the
lower third or in the mid face so for
every dynamic movement of the the
forehead botolan toxin is the right
treatment
and so you can actually provide a better
charisma for a patient also you have a
chemical brow lift and so the eyebrow
raises due to a new balance of muscle
activity agonist and antagonist are in a
new relationship so as a result you will
raise your eyebrows and if the eyes
would appear you look more fresh more
aware more interested in your frame you
know so yeah right it's just a warmer
and more elegant appearance and also
when when you when you are stressed by
the light stressed by an argument of
your opponent you you don't frown
anymore so you your cool and what about
this volume of therapy everybody's
talking about right this is now
hyaluronic acid and in former times we
have injected Tyler Annika acid just
under the skin we actually filled the
wrinkles but not so long and not so
anymore since quite a long time now six
to eight years we injecting more deep
into the deeper layers of the soft
tissue a flap of the of the face and by
actually injecting on to the bone we can
correct with little amounts of
hyaluronic acid tremendous surface in
reality because I black boot chops are
one of the most common cosmetic
surgeries performed what are the options
well there so many different approaches
to refine the breast since the breast is
number one mostly asymmetric and the
deformations can be so different so you
have to evaluate the skin you have to
evaluate the proportion and the
asymmetry and also then the connective
tissue what gives actually the shape to
the breast so if you need an implant or
just reposition and reduce the skin
needs to be diagnosed by a highly
trained specialists with a lot of
experience
and this is what I would advise if
anything is in kind of a future interest
of the viewers of this program program
then I would really suggest to look in
the internet for a good well known a
breast surgeon and get consultation so
this is one of the keys if I'm looking
for a cosmetic surgeon anyway so I have
to talk to many different surgeons or
what should I do well you cannot travel
throughout the whole world and and a big
name is not always the right physician
for you so number one I would get
information through the via the internet
and then I really advise to really visit
the one and only who I will trust in the
future and only if my guts will tell me
that this is the right situation I'm
getting in then I can believe in it and
trust in it so it looked it sounds a bit
stupid but it's there's more truth in it
than you then you believe in the
beginning and then of course you need to
check the results and and ask the
questions and and then you make a
decision if you want or not this is one
thing I want to say in aesthetics the
patient actually sets the indication
what it means if you have high blood
pressure then the doctor will tell you
you take these pills otherwise you will
be very sick in aesthetics the doctor is
my coach and I will tell yes or no so
it's a totally different situation of
the different enzymes and the page the
patient actually should be aware of this
so the patient is in the driver's seat
not the doctor okay go to know getting
back to group drops yes our implants
always a solution or of the different
kinds of methods you can do it to
enlarge the press well it always depends
because not every patient will have one
to have a big breasts and it's a matter
of proportion how is the body size and
how actually is the excess of the skin
sometimes skin reduction and reposition
you of the fat is enough volume and you
don't need an implant but in a lot of
cases you need an implant
then you need to know which kind of
implant and there's several kinds of
coding which are then more adherent to
the to the tour X and so you will have a
long-lasting good result in others they
slip more then you have different
profiles like round shaped and
anatomically shaped so a lot of
differences you need to be aware of so
you can even take fat from different
parts of the body and re translocated
even that it's possible but you have to
be aware that when you transplant fat
there's always a problem that the take
of the fat in that new position is not
always one hundred percent and then
there's little scars which can be
identified as a might be a problem in in
in a mammogram and so you get confused
if you want to see how the gynecologist
could have problems afterwards finding
out if you've cups and cancer doctors at
us so thank you so much for being with
us in the program today thank you
you